ustedes
me están viendo
ok
me estás mirando
ojalá haya habido alguna duda entre una
respuesta y la otra porque no da lo
mismo ver que mirar les propongo una
pequeña experiencia cortita no
obligatoria los que tengan ganas busquen
el que tengan cerca más cerca y
sostengan la mirada unos segundos no
pasa nada
bueno
obviamente que no le voy a preguntar si
pasó algo entre ustedes
pero me muero de curiosidad
pero tengo casi la certeza que algo pasó
porque insisto no es lo mismo ver que
mirar o ver es cuestión del ojo es
cuestión del yo yo veo que aquí hay
mucha gente que hay hombres que hay
mujeres que hay familias que luces
cuando miro miro con todo mi ser con
todo mi ser por eso cuando un grupo de
turistas por ejemplo se está frente al
mismo paisaje son los algunos se les
escapó una grimón
principito parece que tenía razón que lo
esencial es invisible a los ojos
qué problema tiene la mirada
fundamental de mi mirada nada sé
si alguien te pregunta por qué vivirá
así
y como te miro
no lo sé si voy a un espejo a buscar eso
en el espejo me encuentro con los ojos
la mirada la perdí en el camino porque
la mirada se construye siempre en el
encuentro con el otro por eso tantas
historias de amor empiezan con la mirada
o no chicos conocí a alguien
no saben cómo vivir
me va a hablar de hola
y cuántas historias de amor terminan
antes que el otro te diga que no te
quiero más pero en su mirada encontrar
la nada misma
es que la mirada tiene elementos
inconscientes y manejables no la puedo
construir
prueben si esta noche tienen un sábado
prometedor de ensayar una mirada sexy
prueben toda la casa y decir quiero
tener una mirada de padre madre en
cannes y resulta que estoy viviendo como
los adams o como los simpson
prueben los docentes de hacer una mira
del pichi mahuída
no sale si es que perdida porque hace un
docente o si es que nunca lo tuve
vivimos mirando y siendo mirados vivimos
convocando miradas mira me contó te
hablo le dice el padre no son su hijo
la docente al borde de un ataque de
nervios' chicos si no me miran como me
van a atender un docente que intentaba
sorprender a los alumnos el día que yo
fui era con un casco blanco con luces
intermitentes
ha sido la matemática
y pregunte viene siempre con casco no no
tiene pelucas de todos colores
y yo dije
equivocación
algún marido con plata quizás que le
compra las pelucas son carísimas no pero
después pensé hace ese esfuerzo para ser
mirado o visto
quizás mirada de ahí a que sea atendido
hace falta un paso más
hace falta proponer algo interesante
yo fui docente 33 años y me pasaron
cosas con la mirada
más de dos veces y en eso soy muy
freudiana aprendí con freud que cuando
algo te pasa más de dos veces lo tenés
que analizar
qué me pasaba coloquio de fin de años
residentes y cooperamos conmigo un
excelente examen un 10
y cuando terminaba firmaba la libreta y
le decía por qué no participaron en
clases y sabían tanto porque si
guardaron este saber por qué no me
compartieron con sus compañeras no
produce yo el mar se le hice una
pregunta y usted me miró de una manera
que yo nunca más me animé a preguntar
a la vocación docente
entonces mis clases a veces empezaban
así chicos hola soy liliana tengo ojos
grandes
soy hipo tiroidea parece que mis ojos
son muy decidor es y cada tanto
paralizan a alguien que se queda sin
hacer preguntas y ustedes futuras y
cooperador no se lo pueden permitir al
lado del instituto y un barcito que
justamente se sana sin cobrar
qué tal si nos tomamos un café y
hablamos de lo que nos pasa con las
miradas porque ustedes futuras y copias
agudas van a pasarse la vida mirando
pacientes padres familias escuelas
docentes directivos y uno se pueden dar
el lujo de paralizarse con la mirada
mucho menos que se les suspendan las
preguntas porque cuando uno se deja de
preguntar deja de aprender y un
psicopedagogo que debe aprender es como
raro no porque me disciplina nuestra
culpa de eso
vivimos mirando vivimos siendo admirados
la tecnología empezó a entrar en
nuestras vidas y ahí algo pasó así como
les dije recién que no pueden construir
una mirada lo que les quiero decir que
las miradas construyen subjetividad
impactan en el sujeto
no da lo mismo que un bebé se encuentra
al nacer con una mirada amorosa de maná
que le transmite el amor por la mirada
porque si les dice te quiero te quiero
te quiero te quiero el bebé no entiende
nada porque no tiene universo
lingüístico ni simbólico para entender
que él te quiero es el amor la mirada lo
atraviesa qué pasará con estos bebés que
se encuentran con mamás que no pueden
dejar los celulares o las pantallas
mientras dan de mamar
que pasarán con estos niños que están
almorzando con el sapo pepe con pe papi
con patadas y no con miradas amorosas de
padres que se ponen re felices cuando
come toda la papilla o padre que pueden
dejar la pantalla para escuchar cómo les
va en la vida en el patio en el aula con
los amigos qué pasará con estas familias
que han dejado hackear el diálogo y la
comunicación entre ellos porque no puede
ver ni almorzar ni cenar sin pantallas
que para sara con las escuelas que no se
animan a romper filas queridos docentes
rompamos filas si no pasan de las
pantallas a las nucas de los compañeros
nos sentemos en mesas que hagan trabajo
cooperativo que investiguen que se miren
que se escuchan que se conozcan que
aprendan de la diversidad de esa
diversidad que se pone en juego en
cualquier mesa de trabajo en un aula
nuestros chicos nacieron
y los estaba esperando la tecnología yo
no me creo que nacieron nativos
digitales no hay prueba de saber que
nacieron nativos digitales y sé que
nacieron en una sociedad que los
esperaba con las pantallas desde muy
chiquititos y los chicos de todo el
mundo han querido tener lo que ven en la
mano de sus padres
la tecnología es una herramienta
maravillosa llegó para quedarse
tendremos cada vez más pero siempre que
esté usada a favor del ser humano
no siempre es así y saben que no conozco
ninguna herramienta tecnológica que le
dé sentido a la vida si no no tendríamos
tantos suicidios adolescentes
el sentido de la vida se encuentra con
un turismo interno buscando adentro de
uno mismo para que vine al mundo que
quiero ser que quiero hacer y eso no me
lo da la tecnología es un viaje es un
viaje con muchas estaciones y en cada
estación siempre hay un otro o unos
cuantos otros y ojalá ahí aparezcan las
coordenadas del amor ojalá porque de no
aparecer el camino hacia la soledad y
los psiquiatras nos dicen que la mayor
causa de depresión a cualquier edad es
la soledad el hombre no nació para estar
solo lo dijo dios no en una vez el
arruinado la vida dan pero bueno y con
lo bueno que el hombre esté solo y
aparecemos las evas pero bueno el
sentido de la vida hay que encontrarlo a
adentro de uno mismo
a dentro de uno mismo en ese viaje que
les estoy proponiendo donde las
herramientas tecnológicas no nos ayudan
nos ayudan el otro el encuentro con el
otro el encuentro humano con el otro la
verdad que me da pena ver niños solos me
da pena pacientitos que se quejan de la
soledad del aula de la soledad en el
recreo de que no suena no suelen el
teléfono los fines de semana para
juntarse en un momento de amistad y esa
es una deuda que tenemos nosotros con la
infancia y quiero compartirlo con
ustedes pero les quiero dejar esa deuda
el mismo tiempo una estrategia que le
aprendí de la mano de un hombre con una
mirada impresionante eduardo galiano el
escritor uruguayo que mirada y que vos
en ese cuento fabuloso sobre el mar
donde ese mérito que quería conocer el
mar le pide el padre que lo lleve el
padre lo lleva y cuando aparece el mar
en toda su inmensidad el niño temblando
le toma la mano el padre dice papá papá
a ayudarme a mirar
la obligación de los adultos es ayudar a
mirar a la infancia porque el mundo es
muy complejo es muy difícil y no entro
prácticamente como en mi época que no
había pantallas
hoy los chicos aprietan un botón y les
puede entrar el mundo si no estamos
nosotros ahí filtrando y eligiendo por
ellos
además de saldar esa deuda con la
infancia deseo profundamente que nos
reencontremos que sus amos esta grieta
que nos separa que no es más que el
fruto de la intolerancia frente al
diferente al que piensa el que sienta el
que sueño distinto que nosotros no nos
merecemos que nos vengan quitando
humanidad no nos merecemos los mismos de
la posmodernidad el individualismo el
egoísmo el narcisismo el capitalismo el
consumismo el ya mismo el laborismo todo
eso nos resta humanidad
y ustedes me dirán cómo hacemos para
causar la grieta con qué tipo de mirada
y las miradas tienen que ser amorosas
pacíficas e inclusivas pero liliana nos
acaba de decir que no se pueden
construir no no se puede pero si
queremos tener miradas amorosas si
queremos que nuestras miradas acarician
al otro y no lo lastimen tenemos que
trabajar sobre nosotros mismos sobre
nuestro propio mundo mirándonos y
escuchando nuestro deseo viendo que nos
falta hacer para ser felices buscar esa
felicidad buscar ese sueño frustrado esa
asignatura pendiente' trabajar los
enojos rodearme de gente positiva y
sobre todo volver esperanza armé porque
es una deuda que tenemos con los
adolescentes si nos ven desesperanzados
a ellos les va a costar mucho mucho
armar un concepto de vida
quisiera decir lo que decía el tano
serrat hoy puede ser un gran día para
soltar la emoción para volver a
comunicarnos para encontrarnos con la
unidad
no dejemos que las pantallas saquen los
tiempos del amor
de verdad hoy puede ser un gran día para
volver a mirarnos en la tarde
ah
y